he's Tim kalma shine he's a star B star
of around the horns what he has told me
before the biggest name on there the
best writer on there and very popular
these are his words obviously and a
great columnist and has his finger on
the pulse when it comes to the Dallas
Cowboys hi Tim how are you
you finally read that introduction I
said to you thank you well that's the
way it was supposed to be written yep
woody page sends me the same one but but
hey all right so help us out here with
the Ezekiel Elliott story your reaction
how big is this story right now in
Dallas oh it's huge I mean it's it's
it's all people are talking about and
it's gone from last week people thought
okay maybe maybe the Commissioner could
have suspended for a game we don't know
why it's completely unfair to you know
cowboy fans thinking I hope he doesn't
get four games just it's just the timing
of it is terrible knowing that this is
supposed to be the week he responds to
the whatever the NFL is fan on and
instead he's he's out getting a bar
fight okay now I'm we know that the the
bar fight has nothing to do with the
sexual assault that those charges were
dropped at Ohio State but the NFL has
been investigating this for almost a
year now I think what what is it that
they're finding out or found out that's
different from the police report that
you're going to perhaps suspend him for
a game or two well that's a real good
question anyways I was two incidents of
domestic violence with his former
girlfriend no charges ever filed but I
think the NFL with their personal
conduct policy they could they could get
rid of you based on perception they did
you know office burger they did it to
hear that they could they could do it
that was before they got serious about
their policy so they could take that and
just this little string of other
incidents the thing is the st. Patrick's
Day party pose the woman's shirt down
all the little stuff all that could fall
into the personal conduct policy now I
don't think any
that adds up to more than two games but
still to Jesus is a lot if you're the
Cowboys of seek Eliot how much concern
is there about Ezekiel Elliott just off
the field
personality-wise I think a lot but it's
not like the concern like he's a bad guy
it's it's more he's a good guy everybody
likes him but he's always been the life
of the party they heard they heard that
story from Ohio State I think there were
stories up there that you know Joey Bosa
stopped hanging out with him because he
didn't want to get into trouble enjoy
Bosa was his roommate so I mean he's
he's a guy who looks to have a little
too much fun a little too often and even
though he always says hey I've learned
my lesson
here's he never has I was told this so
I'm assuming the Cowboys did their
homework that when Ezekiel Elliott was
drafted and dak Prescott I was told by
somebody with the Cowboys that you never
have to worry about dak Prescott but you
always have to worry about Ezekiel
Elliott would you say that's a fair
assessment on both of them I'd say
that's exactly exactly correct there's
people here there are fans here they
call us on radio saying why don't they
just have that you know watch this heat
like facilitative how much can I ask
that to do if you're play quarterback
run the team by the way this guy we pay
five times as much money of you extras
you 145th pick you need to babysit him
for the next four years I also like that
I saw a headline that now we're going to
find out how good dak Prescott is if he
doesn't have Ezekiel Elliott in the
backfield
wait you didn't write that column did
you oh that was not that was somebody
okay wait what happened we are going to
fight that out but I don't know if
that's that's a fair way to do it okay
but what does this do for this team and
if he is suspended you're going to miss
the Giants game obviously a big game but
you do have depth at that
but does it change that much the Cowboys
you know offenses they'll move forward
here you know in a way not a tug that
sounds ridiculous but I mean the year
before Derek stabbed ran for 1,100 yards
and he didn't start the first six games
I mean I think for a game or even two
games there diminished a little bit but
but it's not crippling if it ends up
being four games then they're in big
trouble but as you said the first one is
the Giants you know if they lose that
game and that's part of the reason that
could be the NFC East at the end of the
year still strange the Tony Romo is not
there anymore
very yeah it's weird and did a lot of
people have continued to think he's
going to come back which I'm pretty
certain he's done but yeah it even at
the time it it made sense for to do what
he did but then football season comes
around and you know he can still play he
played a little bit last year you to a
touchdown against against the
quarterback going Carroll the Cowboys
had to go out to choir during the
offseason some reason so yeah it is it
his strange thing he's done
can you see a scenario where another
team would inquire about Tony Romo
during the regular season yeah I mean
that that happened I think twice with
Troy egg was who were tired much younger
I think Troy was like 34 what he retired
uh but I think team's done it's more of
a long shot I think teams know because
of the back and everything else it takes
somebody a long long time he could he
could drop what he was doing and go play
in two weeks I mean he would need mud to
get ready so I don't I don't think I
think it would be an offseason thing I
don't think it would be a regular season
emergency day and by all accounts he's
been doing these practice games that
he's been his criticism has been kind of
harsh if not over-the-top
harsh
did you see that happening with Tony
Romo that he would be a little bit more
critical in this analyst role he got
that from reading my colleges out here
so glad it completed here
and here's going that direction no I
actually thought I thought he'd be funny
and he'd be natural but he would be very
critical so it will be interesting to
see if that really I heard I heard him
saying that it'll be it see that holds
up now he's at CBS so he won't do a lot
of cowboy boots he'll get one or two
cowboy games a year and that will be for
it I think it's tougher for it but maybe
maybe he'll be more open about you know
criticizing the Baltimore Ravens it's
good to talk to you are you on around
the Hornet
today though I love my way to big 12
beauty a day well you've been giving
proper play too on your show while your
playing career salary we've got a
pacific-12 BD a day getting set to go so
I'm signing up there yeah that's going
to be exciting man I I was I was going
to dedicate the final hour of the show
to just big 12 media day but I'm not I'm
not quite sure right now I think you
should yeah yeah a gun DS mullets gone
right yep that's it that's that's the
big news I think so yes that's bad yeah
who's still in the big 12 because I
can't remember did they add it even real
which I don't wear what I think I think
West Virginia's as well are there 12
teams in the big 12 is what I want to
know too
still got it all right you got a strong
dish we got kids or Steve the bee
protection west here well save travels
it should be riveting I can't wait I
can't wait for all those clips that are
going to come out of big 12 media day
let me fall ill result 9 thank you to
see that's Tim Couch own Dallas Morning
News columnist and popular contributor
to around the horn the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience